bonjour merci de nous avoir rejoints
dans fit l'écho ce numéro est consacré à
la rse la responsabilité sociétale des
entreprises
c'est à dire la prise en compte des
impacts sociaux et environnementaux dans
l'activité des entreprises alors qu'est
ce que cela signifie concrètement
c'est ce que nous allons découvrir nous
irons à la rencontre de différentes
entreprises qui ont mis en place une
politique de rse
nous verrons que cela diverses formes
mais tout d'abord nous retrouvons arnaud
comolet chargée de mission développement
durable à la communauté d'agglomération
de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
pour mieux comprendre ce concept arnaud
congolais bonjour alors la
responsabilité sociétale des entreprises
qu'est ce que cela signifie exactement
rse responsabilité sociétale des
entreprises c'est un nom barbare qui
veut qu indique m'a prise en compte par
les entreprises des principes et
questions de développement durable
donc c'est une déclinaison de la
question des développements du
développement durable au niveau de
l'entreprise donc du milieu du monde
économique alors pour l'entreprise ce
qui est original c'est prendre en compte
les questions d'environnement et le
social puisque leurs principales
priorités c'est évidemment la question
du développement économique
concrètement dans les entreprises ça se
matérialise de façon très très
diversifié alors effectivement ça prend
des expressions à ces diverses la plus
commune c'est celle du reporting et
rapports documents communication qui
exprime et qui décrivent les actions
menées par une entreprise en matière de
rse et dans les entreprises en général
ça peut concerner aussi bien le
bien-être des salariés que la palangre
de l'environnement et jamais des
transports ça touche à potentiellement
beaucoup de domaines qui sont des
questions de mobilité puisque lui et
salariés viennent souvent un autre
territoire sacs entassés particulier la
question du logement aussi la question
du bien-être
est ce que c'est une question
d'actualité la question de
l'environnement puisque l'entreprise a
une responsabilité vis à vis du milieu
général et de la nature
ça touche également à l'utilisation la
grande des équipements publics pour que
les salariés
puisse se détendre avoir des activités
sportives de loisirs c'est ça c'est
notre traduction à
saint-quentin-en-yvelines tout ce qui
peut améliorer les relations de
l'entreprise avec son milieu qui est le
territoire de 50
est-ce que c'est finalement quelque
chose d'obligatoire alors il ya un
minimum d'obligations qui découlent du
noir dit m et re qui date de quelques
années qui oblige les grandes
entreprises celles qui sont cotées à la
bourse de publier chaque année un
rapport d'hier et seule responsabilité
dans les entreprises où elles doivent
décrire leurs actions expliqué ce que le
mène en matière essentiellement de
relations sociales et des actions en
faveur de l'environnement dans leur
quotidien comme comme leur stratégie au
delà de ce reporting
finalement ce n'est qu'un plan d'action
il n'y a pas d'obligation au niveau
européen il ya un projet de
développement une stratégie soit la
grèce ce qui évidemment se traduit au
niveau national par un projet de
réglementation qui est en cours actuel
est ce qu elle est divine font figure de
bonne élève
et on peut dire que effectivement ce
territoire est relativement est à ces
pionniers en matière de rse est il
particulièrement à saint quentin en
yvelines dans le développement notamment
d'un réseau c'est-à-dire de de
partenariat entre les entreprises de ce
territoire voire d'autres territoires et
la communauté d'agglomération et aussi
les différents acteurs du territoire
arnaud comme lé merci de nous avoir
reçus je vous en prie je vous propose
maintenant de nous rendre dans une
entreprise qui a intégré ce réseau de
saint quentin en yvelines
il s'agit de nouvelles attitudes son
activité le recyclage de papier de
bureau
c'est une activité forcément écologique
mais nous verrons qu'ils vont bien plus
loin en termes de développement durable
didier toqués bonjour vous êtes
directeur de nouvelles attitudes une
entreprise spécialisée dans le recyclage
de papier de bureau
nous sommes d'ailleurs dans votre centre
de tri à coignières l'autre aspect de
votre entreprise c'est l'aspect social
vous avez été reconnue entreprise de
réinsertion
on a souhaité être entreprise
d'insertion pour justement accompagner
un peu les politiques de rse dont on
parle tant aujourd'hui
finalement si on prend les trois
économies l'économie du profit
l'économie sociale où l'économie
environnementale
aucune d'entre elles ne marchent bien
mais c'est la complémentarité de ses
économies aujourd'hui qui nous intéresse
beaucoup
et on pense que nous qui sommes accès à
la fois sur l'économie sociale qui est
vraiment notre réseau met notre boussole
j'ai envie de dire notre nord et
l'économie environnementale par notre
activité de recyclage
on peut aujourd'hui trouver des systèmes
de coopération avec les entreprises du
secteur lucratif à juste titre pour être
encore plus performant dans toutes ses
activités
concrètement comment ça c'est décline
vous proposer des formations vous sortez
des personnes un peu isolée du chômage
alors pour ce qu'on appelle les parcours
d'insertion c'est à dire des gens
éloignés de l'emploi qui viennent chez
nouvelle attitude
notre vocation c'est que sur une période
maximum de 24 mois on retrouve un emploi
pérenne aux personnes qui passent ici on
professionnelle parce qu'on appelle les
métiers de valoriste valorise collecte
qui vont chercher le papier les
entreprises et vallauris entrepôts comme
vous pouvez le voir par exemple en ce
moment
quitterie qui conditionne qui prépare le
papier ces métiers de valorisation des
matières premières secondaires que l'on
jette sont aujourd'hui des métiers
d'avenir et ils permettent aussi très
dépasserait particulièrement efficace
vers ce qu'on appelle les éco industries
quand on sait communiquer recyclé peut
apparaître à pied on sait le faire bros
plastique on sait faire pour carton etc
donc on pense que c'est vraiment des
métiers d'avenir quand on accueille un
candidat de votre entreprise
on les fait sur un parcours spécial
pendant quatre mois finalement on
regarde comment le candidat travail
se comportent respecte les instructions
de sécurité etc qui ont su pendant huit
mois
on va avec des chargés d'insertion des
personnels spécialisés définir avec eux
leur parcours professionnel et amener
des formations qualifiantes qui vont
vers ce parcours professionnel et notre
dernière mission qui est la plus
importante quelque part c'est fait des
passerelles vers l'emploi donc vers les
entreprises du secteur économique
globale et c'est là où on a des tas de
choses à se dire encore sur saint
quentin en yvelines
au-delà de cet aspect environnemental et
social le troisième volet c'est l'aspect
économique que vous n'oubliez pas et
finalement d'être concurrentiels et
votre entreprise fonctionne très bien
95 % de notre chiffre d'affaires c'est
nous qui allons chercher donc c'est nous
qui allons chercher nos clients à qui on
proposait programme de recyclage des
opérations d archivage des opérations de
destruction confidentiel donc
effectivement la condition de réussite
tout ça c'est d'être de bons
entrepreneurs sociaux dans notre domaine
d'activité principal et c'est ce qu'on
essaie de prouver tous les jours vous
êtes développer également vous allez
ouvrir bientôt un troisième centre il ya
deux ans
on fait en accord avec la poste du
grossiste et d'année en année alors je
trouve que ça c'est d'une grande
modernité et c'est un petit peu
l'illustration de ces nouveaux principes
de coopération qui peuvent exister entre
des groupes et des structures de
l'économie sociale et solidaire qu'on
représente aujourd'hui sur un concept
simple c'est que tous les jours le
facteur va déposer dans une entreprise
du papier courrier quelque part on a
imaginé de dire mais quand on dépose
duvalier courrier pourquoi on reprend
pas du papier à recycler par un système
de logistique inversée qui est un
système environnemental extrêmement
moderne en ce moment ça veut dire
qu'aujourd'hui la camionnette de la
poste qui partait plein et qui revenait
vide par plein et reviennent l'un est
donc là on est sûr la logique que
j'évoquais tout à l'heure c'est à dire
d'essayer de piloter la boussole
environnementale la boussole sociale et
la boussole économiques qui n'ont pas
les mêmes normes et avec lequel on peut
faire des choses tout à fait
intéressante
alors pour conclure vous avez finalement
intégrer le système économique de demain
on a même été encore plus loin parce que
quand je vous dis qu'on doit livrer du
papier hop à petit on a passé un
accord-cadre national avec l'ensemble
des papetiers recycleurs pour leur dire
d'abord on vous garantit que tout ce
qu'on collecte c'est pour vous ça reste
sept matières premières restent sur le
territoire
la deuxième chose qu'on le rallye c'est
donnez nous la répartition dans vos
usines ensemble du gisement qu'on est
capable de collecter et on l'a fait ça
pour essayer de définir des principes de
proximité les plus judicieux possible en
termes de transport et de logistique
parce que le recyclage et beaucoup de
transport donc minimiser les choses
gardiez la richesse au sein d'un
territoire
parce que notre vocation sociale c'est
aussi créer de l'emploi non
délocalisable sur les territoires et
puis garantir un accord à long terme
avec appétit compris sur des logiques de
prix qui nous permette en tant
qu'industriel de début de chaîne quand
on collecte jusqu'à la recyclage éclaté
quand on finit la chaîne des plots plus
performant possible
c'est donc une filière vertueuse 100%
confiance aujourd'hui qu'on propose aux
entreprises
le ps paie le point services aux
particuliers un lieu de médiation
sociale attrape se rend régulièrement
mustapha aujourd'hui il vient chercher
un appui pour ses démarches
administratives et avec tous ses papiers
il y a de quoi s'y perdre
mustapha compte revenir bientôt pour ses
factures d'énergie après j'ai fait le
pape et pour l'extrait cité pour vous
approprier pour ses chers louis les 4
700 clic mandat louis moi j'ai gagné
magique années 1950 euros à 950 euros
on n'aurait pas vu l'ombre d'un vaccin
comme moustapha sy si beaucoup de
personnes connaissent des difficultés
financières et sociales
bien souvent ces personnes ont perdu le
contact avec les entreprises leur
fournissant au gaz ou encore électricité
alors ces mêmes entreprises participent
au financement de l'association pour que
leurs clients ne se retrouvent pas en
situation d'impayés est coupée en eau en
énergie une action intégrée au volet
social de leur politique de rse et en
dix ans d'activité les retours sont
assez positifs ils sont bien contents
qu'on puisse leur expliquer les systèmes
de facturation des entreprises les
organisations aussi des entreprises
exemple qu'un paiement par chèque ça
mais quinze jours donc voilà on peut se
retrouver on a payé même si on a envoyé
le chèque dans la base de données de ces
entreprises là tchèque mais 15 juin
arrivée les gens se retrouvent en
impayés quoi autre exemple concret de
l'aide apportée une personne qui a
changé de compte bancaire sans en
informer la compagnie d'eau l'acv sq
cet usage est donc à vinh une mensualité
de 30 euros qui a été rejetée par an 10
mois d'affilée il ne s'est pas
manifestée pour nous c'est un impayé
puisqu'on a derrière un rejet de
prélèvement
le fait que l'usagé se soit présentée
aux psp et il est discuté avec le
médiateur qu'est ce que va faire le
médiateur il va l'inviter à nous
recontacter pour souscrire à nouveau un
prélèvement sur son bon compte bancaire
depuis avril 2011
là c est ce qu a signé une convention de
partenariat avec le psp à la clé un
financement de 10 mille euros par an et
une participation aux actions de
l'association comme des ateliers pour
apprendre
les éco gestes pour réduire ses factures
le psp espère élargir ce type de
partenariat à d'autres entreprises
donc l'eau l'électricité le gaz ça
concerne la fracture énergétique on est
aussi en train d'essayer de travailler
sur les problématiques de la fracture
numérique
voilà on essayant de travailler avec des
entreprises comme free et sait faire
monter des partenariats avec emmaüs pour
proposer des tarifs adaptés aux gens les
plus en difficulté on essaye en fait de
développer les partenariats entreprises
voilà en fonction des problématiques
qu'on ait des difficultés que
rencontrent les habitants au quotidien
pour le moment 40 % des financements
proviennent de fonds privés un moyen
pour les entreprises concernées de ne
pas exclure une partie de leur clientèle
avant de se quitter on passe à l'agenda
de dates à retenir concernant la rse
tout d'abord le 23 mai la maison de
l'emploi et de la formation organisent
une matinée d'information pour apprendre
les principaux éco gestes qui réduiront
vos factures d'énergie rendez-vous de
9h30 à 11h30 à la cité des métiers
attrape deuxième rendez vous le 18 juin
pour la troisième édition de la journée
rse à saint quentin en yvelines
martin hirsch sera présent ainsi que de
nombreuses entreprises du département
pour apporter leur témoignage en termes
de rse
l'acv sq nouvelle attitude mais aussi
bout et guy renaud ou encore la poste
l'entrée est libre mais il faut
s'inscrire vous retrouvez toutes les
informations utiles sur le site internet
qui s'affiche à l'écran
c'est la fin de ce fil échos merci de
nous avoir suivi on se retrouve pour un
prochain numéro le 24 mai